ça fait je vais me mettre à jour mais
ben oui pour faire exemplaires devant
jean-louis donc jean-michel voilà je
sens qu'on a on qu'on a du feeling même
si vous ne sentez pas encore je suis
toujours un petit peu en avance donc je
compte sur vous pour me lever au propre
comme au figuré parce que je suis pas
sûr que je vais pouvoir me relever là
j'espère vous faire craquer au moins
autant que mes genoux crack en ce moment
voilà donc c'est jean-michel voulez vous
coucher avec moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est la gratuité
j'en connais un qui va passer de ce nom
mais ce soir malheureusement je suis
prêt il nous demande un autre genre mais
heureusement c'est demain demain ce à
quoi je suis en demain oui demain